wann mein name ist luca banti
befreundete arzt beim letzten mal so
mega gut ankam habe ich mir gedacht
reagiere ich heute einfach nochmal mit
dem trecker auf zu holz zu ende
hyman wer will ich auch jetzt gerade
wenn ihr das video gerade bin ich in der
türkei urlaub aber leider mit region
sandra von da ist es auch nicht so
richtig urlaub das ist echt schwer dem
verlangen nicht nachzugeben leute ja
alles klar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der hatte doch was mit der lampe am ende
der letzten folge wie ich gespannt wie
viel geld die verloren haben
die von der kann er den namen
oregano
oder sag ich auch organisch manchester
und ich haben immer spaß zusammen
es ist schon vom niveau her ganz tief
nach ihrem 3000 dollar chris mit corey
gestern abend machen glory und die
mädels erst mal eine lagebesprechung
habe er in die nacht mit einem edel wie
die nacht
die die haben doch nicht nur geküsst
oder sehe ich das falsch müsste ich hab
mal vorstellen hätten zu beginn
hunderttausend jetzt sind die bei der
hälfte ja wir haben geknutscht
es war schön das haben wir gesehen
beim kannten die sich haltenden tag oder
sohn alles was chloe also unsere lampe
gelernt hat waren scheint in luft
aufgelöst sowie ihr gehirn sie hat den
preis einer chanel tasche verknüpft
er hat was ich will als ich und hat
tattoos also um klar zu gefallen muss
man einfach nur seien größer als sie
unter tools haben
[Musik]
das ist ziemlich einfach ich sehe das
mit den 3000 dollar nach aber ich hoffe
wirklich dass es ihm mag und sie eine
verbindung aufbauen mensch wie soll denn
sonst unsere nicole er hat ja noch nicht
alles von mir gesehen
ich bin so vielseitig die leichteste
hier hat sich ein filetstück ergattert
und ich wette ergibt vorher jetzt damit
an
die zwei regelbrecher
hat irgendwann schon mal ein anderer typ
die rehau schorsch und
eigentlich hat jeder schon mal so
gefühlt die regel geboren außer ich also
netflix werde noch wen braucht für
staffel 2 sie ist cool und hübsch aber
ich flirte mit jeder denkt vielleicht
dass es mir werden könnte ja aber ich
bin hier um
[Musik]
ja
das ist dann vielleicht die falsche
glaube du kapierst nicht warum es hier
geht
warum machen wir uns eigentlich die
mühle moment
ist in allen das preisgeld scheiß egal
geworden
sie haben nur noch die hälfte
sie hätten alle mit doppelt so viel geld
raus gehen können
und mit meiner erfahrung und ich weiß es
alle waren kaufen würde ich auch mal das
ist nicht mein problem dass sie offen
steht
jetzt noch mal voll the bailout money
corrie hat sich an wie so ein kleiner
kag toyota der neue toyota corrie mit
klimaautomatik in juden ich kann nichts
dafür dass ich schön und witzig bin und
eine tolle persönlichkeit habe
das wird kein toyota über sich jemals
sagen nur von toyota allen die machen
die geile autofahrer morgens früh um 4
uhr 40 mitten im toyota zum düsseldorfer
flughafen
ich weiß nicht warum wir nicht von köln
aus in die türkei fliegen re wird die
flüge gebucht
das kann nur schiefgehen apropos türkei
oder allerdings meine liebe freunde ich
bin dort von jetzt wenn ihr das video
seht bin ich schon längst da allerdings
bin ich doch eine woche das heißt ihr
merkt auch hier gerade schon dass nur
jeden zweiten tag ein neues video kommt
ich habe auch schon in der instagram
story erklärt aber jetzt haben immer auf
youtube für alle die mir auf instagram
nicht folgen ich bin im urlaub und wie
immer wenn ich in urlaub gefahren bin
war es für mich so hey ich bin eine
woche weg das heißt die woche davor
mache ich jeden tag zwei videos damit
jeden tag gekommen
davor habe ich doppelt so viel stress da
bin ich im urlaub ganz klar sei aber
dass auch kein urlaub deswegen habe ich
mir gesagt jetzt über den urlaub nicht
im zweiten tag ein video ich kein
bisschen entspannen und die schirn
punkte hinterher in ceska wäre meine
erste wahl
man höre dass atari nicht mit hab spaß
gemeint stimme vor
und er kommen sich noch in die quere für
francesca und dann gibt es ja auch noch
mich aber der bro code ist wichtiger als
kennt euch halt wirklich dass die haben
alle schon so cool miteinander sind so
alles erzählen offen stehen so die
kennen sich jetzt seit einem tag oder
merkt wenn du meinen namen sagst es sind
nur noch ein paar tage hier übrig und
ich mag wo wir stehen
du sitzt aber gerade es gibt noch eine
letzte hürde
ich muss schon von meinem sohn erzählen
[Musik]
so völlig aus dem nichts
es gibt noch eine letzte hürde muss mir
noch von meinem sohn erzielen
und meinen drei ehemännern und
eigentlich heißt sie auch gar nicht
freunde sondern fritz die wenigsten
männer lernen meinen sohn kennen aber
daran habe ich ein gutes gefühl
ich habe nur angst vor seiner reaktion
ja da hätte ich auch schutz vor wo ich
kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen wenn
ich ein kind haben sollte und mit der
frau nicht mehr zusammen bin von der das
kind ist dass dann eine neue person in
die familie rein kommt die dabei ganz
ganz komische situation irgendwie sich
verletzbar zu machen erfordert mut plane
einen reinen mädels workshop geplant der
sich ganz und gar dem weiblichen
powerman prozess widmet groß
am neuen workshop
jetzt mal was
für die jungs irgendwie wohl
umgeschrieben haben uns mit schlamm
beschmiert haben und keine ahnung was
aber jetzt entscheidet wie die mädels
bin ich gespannt wie das so an kommen
wir bei der ganzen zeit dazwischen harry
anhänger schloss ich wollte es mit case
probieren habe aber nach einem tag
gemerkt dass es nicht passt
ja
das ging relativ schnell
ja alles hat seinen grund vielleicht
machst du noch mehr fehler machst du
noch mehr fehler alles klar
meine frau her sage
hat also bestimmt seine klamotten sind
cool sein haar sitzt er riecht echt gut
und er kann flirten ohne ende bleibe bei
harry der kann nur rugby schreiben
aussehens teil was man so noch schneller
harry einfach sowie lässt gerade die
muskeln für deine frau spielen
du wirst eine rakete war sie mal was die
flirten gerade so extrem und von chester
als eigentlich mit harry also das finde
ich ein bisschen komisch
wenn ich das an harry stelle nachher
sehen würde im fernsehen oder halt auf
netflix da würde ich mich aber dreimal
umdrehen da kann koring nicht
widerstehen
da stimme ich dir zu frauen wieder
stehen nicht gerade die stärke hat sich
noch gar nicht gemeldet in der heutigen
folge
irgendwie hat dieser workshop auch noch
immer nicht gespart wird vor ihm ist
aufgefallen dass du bemüht bist einige
der mädels näher kennenzulernen würdest
du gerne mit einer frau deiner wahl auf
ein date gehen um
ich dachte erst er wird rausgeschmissen
weil er so die komplette gruppendynamik
durcheinander gebracht hat
er wird mit einem date belohnt das macht
doch keinen sinn
die antwort ist dann ist wirklich ende
ein schuss kam
[Musik]
wow
ich hoffe da fliegen fäuste
in dieselbe falle wie ich aber ich halte
mich zurück und sage nichts dazu
in der nächsten folge steht einiges an
allerdings würde ich an der stelle die
heutige reaktion oft motto händel jetzt
erst mal beenden meine lieben freunde
bock drauf habe dass ich in der nächsten
session bei dem date von francesca und
kombi auch nochmal mit dem trecker
darauf reagiere dann lass den daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da und bei
40.000 likes werde ich das machen
und jetzt befinden uns auch im auto
meiner lieben freunde findet hier oben
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn er darauf
könnte man kann als kostenlos abonnieren
dort um ist auch mein shop eingeblendet
in dem am 20
17.50 und dieses t shirt die launischen
würzen jeder bestellung erhaltet ihr
eine von mir handsignierte
autogrammkarte und hier ist meine letzte
action auf tournee eingeblendet also
schaut euch das auch gern noch mal an
[Musik]